I'm here with Neil deGrasse Tyson star
of cosmos space time host of cosmos we
have real stars sure all stars
host I'm not one of the stars I'm the
host so so tell me how involved you are
in cosmos which is would you call it
like a reboot of the Carl Sagan that's
that term has been used but what we did
was we look to see what all the most
awesome stuff was of the original
appearance of the series back in 1980
the real things were carried forward is
how we go about telling the sorts of
stories of science and that's what makes
it different from any other attempt to
bring science to television there's a
literal and figurative vehicle for
telling the story the subtitle here is a
spacetime Odyssey how do you move around
to where you got to go so I have a
spaceship actually the ship responds to
my thoughts there's no buttons or
anything the bottom of the ship opens up
and it is the past and the ceiling opens
up it is the future and then the
panoramic windows is everywhere will be
part you want these messages as a
message of science and our culture and
our relationship to ourselves people who
are sure they don't like science will
have access to it and people who never
knew they would like science would have
access to it and primetime on Fox that's
exactly where it's going and that's
exactly why and after I'm just going to
Bahamas